нам тільки що прийшла Інформація що
прямо зараз відбувається засідання
комітету з питань енергетики а Вибачте а
що це за історія ви давали таке
доручення рада давала таке доручення Ні
не відбувається засідання просто дружнє
спілкування членів комітету без воно не
протоколю не протоколюється рішення не
приймаються ми це вже з'ясували артуре
Володимирович трошки раніше нас тепер
нас тепер комітети називаються дружним
спілкуванням а депутати не можуть
збиратися вже просто кави Поти в онлайні
на вимогу комітета ну яка різниця де
Вони збираються якщо нема протоколу і
рішень це не засідання
Комі Може в нас і тут дружнє спілкування
це не засідання тут Ні тут пленарне
засідання яке триває розгляд правок
відбувася Ну так а Таким чином от мені
буде цікаво чи буде протокол чи будуть
рішення комітету відносно цього числа